oh wie schön es erinnert mich an
irgendetwas an bord das richtige so
krass ich richtig willkommen zu einer
neuen folge drei kopfball an heute mit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin ich schon ich bin 22 jahre alt
und ich trinke gerne aber ich bin auch
ich bin 20 jahre alt - ein jahr ist das
thema ich hab von chemischen gelesen
drei deutsche ein zweites thema drei
sternzeichen kopf wir haben alle
geschaut was unser sternzeichen
eigenschaften hat die
charaktereigenschaften hat und auf diese
eigenschaften müssen einen kopf machen
und wir stellen jetzt unsere zuvor so
leistet wir waren eben einen weg diese
einfach so schön so eine reihe stehen
und mein gott sind wir aufgefallen
also mal zutaten sind nicht sehr kreativ
ich muss nicht viel selber machen ich
habe einfach klasse oder tetra pak
kaufen wir haben einmal salate sehr
saubere software sagt auch auf deutsch
ich hatte natürlich auch frische
erdbeeren kaufen können und die
zerstampfen können aber und das bin ich
einfach nicht dass mein sternzeichen
nicht lange wir einmal ein grundprodukt
das womit alles fällt und steht jack
daniel's fans sage ich schon was wir
standen ja das auch so schon sagen ach
ich kenne das sagt carius dann geht es
weiter mit dem guten maß kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch ist ein
planet
oder wenn die queen berliner luft kleine
stadt und dann natürlich der chili make
up nicht fehlen
dieser kandidat stellt zutaten vor ich
habe eben so
den brauchen wir unbedingt genauso wie
diesen ich habe meine brille ist schön
zu sehen dass man ziehen dann geschont
dann habe ich ganz besonders das thema
verpackung weil ich habe das ganz
wichtig sich in der heidelberger st aber
es war halt blaue deswegen sondern im
moment zitronen spielrunden spirulina
kombucha also ich mag das schon sehr
gerne ja aber ich habe doch
hauptsächlich genommen oder um jemand
hier sollte ich würde dann das hat super
zusammen steinzeichen passen oder so
ausgeglichen dass aber dazu später mehr
er soll einfach ein schütteltrauma der
erste schritt richtung entspannung ist
getan nicht so entspannung kenne ich
hatte da auch den das ist sogar der
kampf ist das logo namens auch besser
durch den er ja ich bin auch das passt
besser zu haben eine vage weil ich bin
nämlich frage fokussierung der ist ganz
wichtig meinte ich habe irgendwie auch
einfach alles gepasst
irgendwie
etwas ganz besonders stachelbeeren und
die ganze stadt so richtig mache werden
in diesem handwerk rund 7 20 metern den
1 es ist vielleicht besser bei den kanal
town das sind in den fluten
danke für die zurückliegenden jahre
aber die wollte ich gerne mit dir teilen
auf der straße
ich würde eher sala dem alkohol an ich
habe schon payne gekauft
euro die flasche
ich habe ja nur ist aber teurer
ansonsten ist meine autos ich habe die
post
es kam ein standard aber ohne alkohol
hast du gesagt ihr könnt ihr bitte sagen
dass einzelne egoisten
das ist mal ein positiver lichtblick war
mein sternzeichen
ja das habe ich verraten und ich bin
jungen frau champagner kuckum war immer
unsere zuckersirup in bar
und da war sich nicole richie und zwei
glocken dieses match ist das aufzuheben
nicht irgendwie sowie bestehe so hier
und da sozusagen und würde sagen mögen
diedorf spiele und da hat
herzlich willkommen zu drei cocktails
und einer den ich fahre also wie
endkosten shaker dampfer das ist spaß
coole also das ist nicht direkt dass
kohl tablette und der blumenkohl war
schwarz und bei den mit rauch asche über
geträufelt haben es hat nach kindern
schmecken
und ich glaube dass ich weiß nicht
worauf die chefkoch
da wird auch mal getroffen findet dieses
bild aber da war auch zocken machen
bekannt geworden doch so viele apps ich
komme gar nicht mehr hinterher auch
möchten die schon tempo ja nee hab ich
schon eine million follower leute die
kommen gerade alle ja gerade erst an
das ist quasi aus und bisschen aber
ziemlich schon absehen dass es eine
mischung auf unsere meinte klopp
da kann man halt auch ökologisch so
coole sachen optik da kann man coole
sachen machen nach santo unicredit hier
können jetzt muss ich das auch nicht
gemacht
die einfach alles so ein sprecher so ein
geschäft welches war das schon mal
jemand gekauft hätte man ja ich dachte
jetzt innovativ zu machen
du musst das abstellen
ich hab mich gerade so mein sternzeichen
entsprechend ist unglaublich sagt
verläuft friends oder siehst du das
ganze vor streiten zu warten wie die
dinge hier
[Musik]
noch heute das tageshoroskop für die
waage liebe waage getränken überhaupt
nicht zu ihrem sternzeichen passen die
woche gecasht wieder den sie gerade
machen um überhaupt das kino freuen
dürfen sie sich über mass ihre kraft ist
jetzt schier endlos das geht so nicht
nur die lawinen sind die voraussetzung
dass ich dass ich mit meinem kopf
ich finde berlin
rihanna soll bereitet denn die berliner
luft hätte hier und bussen der shaker an
berlin weiter wie lange wunde berlins
mit dem ziel eines intensiven muss üben
leute zu interviewen muss man mit
fremden menschen aber auch fremd aber
jetzt auch für sein immer wohnt ja also
jetzt schon ja aber davor habe ich jetzt
auch nicht so nah liegt ihr aber dann
wiederum finde ich auch keine polizei
dafür war immer wenn ich irgendwas
machen sie halt überlegen aber wann
schneide ich dann bei video und so und
ich weiß ja ich kenne ja ich fange ich
das ding nicht ich hoffe jetzt dass es
für schöne ein bisschen zeit für uns ja
aber was wenn nicht gar nicht auftreten
packst du deinen cocktail ich werde mir
auch der sonst so viel glücken wird doch
vor ein kleines zimmer voll zuversicht
ja aber immer sofort die hexen berg und
ich kaufen sind bauern dran hält
du schaffst das markwort man muss auf
die weit dass das kämpfen nur noch ein
bisschen kakaopulver was ist geschüttelt
diese zeit braucht man kann
[Musik]
zero leute man ein dickes problem ist
nicht ein
ich hatte mein gesicht das hier richtig
gar noch das passt zu machen sieht auch
nach so backhaus und sogar und dazu auch
noch packen jetzt sind wir beim feurigen
uns interessant
also gut ja ich wollte halt irgendwas zu
also zum trinken trinken
somit war das für mich zu und jetzt
stelle war und kaufte er jetzt vor wer
ich finde wenn sie fängt an weil du
vorhin zuerst brauche es steckt also wie
ihr alle wisst mittlerweile bin ich wage
und vage sind in dieses bild
unentschlossen so habe ich zwei komplett
gemeint lieber hält waage ist ein luft
zeichen also wollte ich was blaues wie
für den himmel herrscht natürlich den
gegen sagt dagegen dass es nämlich dass
in den blauen cocktails drin ist was so
irgendwie oben hängen was okay wie
kokons minister und sohn kam und in der
das ist alles so auf der erde so weißt
du was ein bisschen so wären weiß nicht
was ich dann noch so ein
und dann habe ich mir noch so ein
kleines debra seien in meiner gruppe ist
auch so ein ja und dieses eis was leider
geschmolzen ist das detail auszubeuten
da stand es leider so sagt er ist so ein
kokon freiwillig entscheiden
und jetzt den gegensatz
ich glaube ich nach sturz und wurde
darum drin also hier ist das programm
ein bisschen sauer aber nicht sauer man
auch nicht so ein bisschen besser
ich hoffe ich bin auch hier über die
versorger hält trinkt war auch wenn er
einen absturz familie irgendwie
symbolisiert aber der rote finde ich das
lied ist du kannst zehn nach dem
training ist schade aber ich finde man
spektrum aber es ist halt take home also
ist nicht angenommen also manchmal damit
so ist nächstes ich glaube mein lieber
sein team laden also ich habe als junge
frau muss sich wegen meinen
charaktereigenschaften einen sehr
perfektionistisch 'nen ordentlichen
gradlinigen kindlichen nicht
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich damit
nicht zu crazy werden und muss mich
irgendwie an etwas teilhaben
das war aber nicht perfekt auf diese
masken jugend also ich war die nicht zur
plage werden weil dies hat ordentlich
plötzlich sahen regelt und sängers
eingemachte bisschen ist quasi schon wie
ein ja und dann aber weil ich halt ein
eher zeichen bin habe ich einen pflanzen
natürlich und irgendwann ist auch er
unter der erde
burke wächst auch im boden erbe und dann
habe ich hier noch den fernsehturm
gemacht weil irgendwas so geradliniges
haben wollte
im champagner ach so weil ich auch sehr
anspruchsvoll wenn die jungfrau sehr
anspruchsvoll deswegen habe ich kann ihn
sehr
also und ja dass sie erkannt hast du
jetzt gehst dungeons genommen wenn ich
nicht aber man hat trotzdem verstanden
wird so war es vereinbart
gucken wir machen das hier ständig im
kreis
ja ich mag gar nicht viel sagen das
gehört sich schmecken
olaf h also ich fand dieses komische das
haben wir schon ganz kleinen ist aber
auch so dass wir so ein getränk so sind
es aber ich mag solche getränke nicht
machst du hier getränk deswegen macht ja
auch den jungen leute was mir und diese
special mit kurkuma und nee da möchte
ich lieber so was ein herz haben kann
ich das ja auch erst einmal das aber
stimmt es ist bestimmt irgendwie heraus
schaaf ich muss sagen ich was mich
gerade bei diesen flächen ich finde man
sprechen das mittelteil irgendwie so aus
diesen ich habe mir das gefühl ist
glaube ich immer durch einen strom gehen
war sehr kalt
andersohn gelaufen jaja finde ich schon
beim dieses metall an der lippe mag ich
ihn wenig ich finds beifall
naja ich hab ja doch einfach mal
getroffen
[Musik]
das ist da kommen wir weiter von dem
sachverhalt frischen und ehrlich dass
ist gut vorbereitet sind ein bisschen
erfrischen meines eher symbolisch warm
reif wie alles ist ist der todesschütze
ein feuer sternzeichen wir hatten lufti
hatten erde und jetzt kommt wie sind die
elemente also ich hab jetzt hier mein
feuer cocktail kreiert aber ich bin
nicht nur ich kann natürlich anders ja
ja ja die feuernation so also ich bin
nicht nur aufhören denkt wir natürlich
auch auf die charaktereigenschaften des
schützens eingegangen natürlich habe ich
erst mal mit meiner starken band
angefangen dem jack daniel's tennessee
feier damit ich doch mit reinbringen der
auch natürlich sehr sehr eine grund note
dieses ganze getränk bringen
dann wissen wir alle dass der mars der
planet das feuer sternzeichen schütze
ist passt perfekt eigentlich wollte ich
bei dem ganzen getränken auch die farbe
rot gehen deswegen habe ich auch noch
den erdbeer strawberry sagt dazu ich
mache
abstimmen und irgendwie das ist der
erste rat nicht so durchgesetzt deswegen
habe ich eher so ein getränk mit einer
leichten rosen note und ich als schütze
bin natürlich auch sehr offen und bin
auch ein bisschen so na also ich möchte
alles erkunden nicht in seine neugierige
auch viel erfahren
da habe ich mir gedacht machte nochmal
so ein crazy betreiben und deswegen habe
ich behindertes kind hier queen geholt
doch mal was kannst du hast einzubringen
weil ich immer mehr erfahren möchte auf
dieser welt klar man weiß auch maß und
mitte
aber dass er trotzdem münster
das ist klar aber dass es so wäre dann
bestimmt auch was natürlich bin ich auch
als schütze ein sehr leidenschaftlicher
mensch
deswegen wollte ich auch noch etwas der
leidenschaftlichsten und zwar diese sehr
sexuell
natürlich ist sie auch fleißig oder soll
man ein bisschen das beißt einbringen
denn ich gerade nur diesen feier
tennessee von jack denn es ist allgemein
habe ich das ganze natürlich auch eher
so ein bisschen nach feuer dekoriert
dass sie natürlich auch dass auch mein
getränk on fire ist wie sehr die vision
geändert
ich bin begeistert dass er fürs erste
mal so krass
na ja probieren wir den partner hast du
die rein gemacht werden zur deckung der
[Musik]
weihnachtsmarkt ja oder nach fisch im
ziemlich schnell ja und man wird wohl
ich war man spürt das feuer in seinem
herzen um hat dann sofort gedruckt ist
die fragebögen wir uns in der baustelle
ja ich muss zu meiner verteidigung sagen
ich war vielleicht ein bisschen
optimistisch mit dem 6 ich hab das doch
mal das ist dass der schütze so
leidenschaftlich und das ist einfach
und deswegen wird man halt auch schnell
die sachen aber dafür gibt man nicht so
viel geld auch weil einfach so viel in
einem trinkt drin ist deswegen wie aus
der sparte warmen ölen ja der worte das
braucht man darum soll man die hitze ok
ja es wird mein getränk auch wirklich
nur im winter dringend wenn man
eigentlich gerade erfriert also da im
schnee sitzt und keine andere
möglichkeit gibt dass ich dich auch
zusammen und das in einer minute darf
nicht geben
pauli geht also darum leben zu retten
also m auch drei sagen wir wir glauben
wir seien tun
[Musik]
juli in jahren
weil sowohl der schmeckt wieder ich
mache mit ihnen hat die 1
ich wollte wieder von marvin kren könnte
besser nicht zu sprache mit den
langsamen aber ich muss für deiner
verteidigung wagen ich habe gedacht ich
kotzen wenn ich das trinken bei der rbs
waren jetzt vorher währenddessen dachte
ich muss ich dachte trinken und das
ausspucken
nein
sorry ja vorher schon mal positiv
überrascht dass man sich die geben
gleich wert hat kein verein auf drei
leute sagen mir wir glauben wenn man hat
eine 23
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ja
17 zu fifa.com
das pen zentrum schuldiger kannst du dir
nochmal das wird dir nicht reinreden
durch das ist genauso oder also zunächst
mal verlinkt sie natürlich beide
[Musik]
[Gelächter]